Hello guys, Chris here. Welcome back to
another Sunday video. In this one, my
friends, I'm going to be testing the
Radeon RX 960 XT 16 GB GPU in 22 games.
Oh yeah, it's finally here. You guys
have been requesting this one a lot. So,
the model that I have here is the XFX
Swift Class Pro Gaming Graphics
960 XT. And just like the other 960 XT
GPUs, it's based on the RDNA 4.0
architecture. It has 248 shading units,
128 TMUs, 64 ROPS, 16 GB of GDDR6 memory
running on a 128 bit memory buzz, and it
has a DDP of 160 watt. However, this is
an OC version of the card, and it boosts
up to 180 watts. So, it has a little bit
more juice than a reference model, for
example. This is also a PCIe 5.0* 16
graphics card, which is very nice to
see, especially at the $350
price point, MSRP at least. But how does
it play games? And is FSR4 any good on
it? Let's find out, shall we? And we're
starting with the beautiful Cyberpunk
2077, guys. We're playing this one at
1440p resolution. utilizing high
settings preset without these options
right here and also without resolution
scaling. For some reason, this defaults
to FSR every time in the preset. So,
this is native 1440p and it's right
around 80 frames per second on average,
dropping into the 70s right now, but I
it's going to be very close to 80. H
yeah, yeah, yeah, come on. There we go.
And guys, in my opinion, this is the
best visuals to performance ratio in
this title, you know. All right, we're
approaching one of the most important
parts of the benchmark run. Goodbye,
Bob. There we go. That was a nice Bob
kill. We managed to bug him as well.
Look at that. Cyber bug again. Oh, yes.
Beautiful. Anyways, around here, this
roundabout is usually pretty intensive
and it gets us still 70 plus FPS. This
is going to be 60 plus 100% of the time
at native 1440p. So, it's quite decent
showing for the 960 XT already. This is
nice. However, I do have one little
complaint and that is this game looks
quite soft at native resolution. If
you're not using any upscaler and
honestly with the upscalers that are
available to this card,
they're not really the best. So, it just
looks shimmery as heck. So, what else
can we test? Let's do like FSR quality.
There's FSR 3, but FSR2.1
actually looks a little bit better in
this title. So, I'm going to use FSR 2.1
here. And whereas the 5060 Ti for
example, when I tried that with the LSS
quality at 1440p with that new
Transformer model in the LSS4, that
looked really good, close enough to the
native resolution stuff. This, well, is
FSR 2.1, so it doesn't look very good.
It's super shimmery right now. It's
still usable if you want a higher
refresh rate experience. But where I
would choose to play with DLSS on the
5060 Ti, I think I wouldn't choose to
play with FSR2 in this one. It's super
unfortunate. Bye, Bob. That this game
doesn't have FSR 3.1 because if it did,
we could use FSR4 and that's really
close to the LSS as I'll show you in
this video later on in games that
support it. But uh yeah, in Cyberpunk, I
don't know why the developers really
don't like to to work on the FSR
implementations, and that's a big big
shame. Let's try some rate racing
presets here. Rater racing ultra. This
enables FSR as well. So, I'm just going
to disable it right away. I'm also going
to disable these options as usual, and
I'll leave everything else as is, and
I'll restart as well. All right, here we
go, guys. This is the performance with
native 1440p rate racing ultra preset.
Now, to be fair, even the 5060 Ti didn't
perform all that well here. It wasn't
really an enjoyable experience. It was
just a little bit faster, but yeah, this
is not playable. FSR 2.1 on quality
gives us 50s, which is much more
playable of course, but it looks too
shimmery, guys. And the reflection look
really bad as well. Like, look at that.
look at at the top of the car. It's just
it's very sad to see this honestly in
Cyberpunk 2077. Once again, I really
hope that the developers introduce FSR
3.1 into the game because that will make
a huge difference. But here for now,
this is what you get. Now, I just
restarted the game. We're with FSR3
quality because that's the only way to
enable frame generation. Everything else
is still the same with rate tracing and
so on. And in terms of input lag, this
is not bad whatsoever. It's pretty much
the same. And uh we're getting 100 FPS.
So that's going to be quite a lot
smoother. Unfortunately though, they
never fixed FSR3's frame generation in
this title. So what I'm seeing here is
still 50 FPS.
It's still broken. What are you doing?
Developers, please stop nerfing FSR and
do it right. But that's about it for
Cyberpunk 2077 Guide. Goodbye, Bob. One
last time. Show some respect. My In the
end, rate racing performance is actually
pretty decent. It would be doable with a
proper implementation of FSR. But as it
stands, I would disable it here in this
title and have a buttery smooth 1440p
high settings experience. Now, it's The
Last of Us Part Two Remastered. This one
actually supports FSR4 out of the box.
If you go here to the Radian Settings,
go to the gaming tab, graphics, and
enable FSR4 here. And that is now active
as you can see. And this is by far the
best anti-aliasing method in this title
to utilize with the 960 XT guys. Uh
frame generation and so on is turned off
at the moment. And we're using the high
settings or very high settings preset,
sorry, without motion blur. And here
we're starting with 50ish frames per
second. That's not amazing, especially
when compared to the 5060 Ti 16 GB GPU
which got 60 to 70 most of the time.
This can still reach 60s as you can see.
But uh yeah, I'd like to have seen 60
plus all of the time, you know. Still
guys, this is way cheaper than that
card. So that also counts for something.
And since FSR4 is in this title, we can
just enable the upscaling here on
quality. And this should make the game
look pretty much the same as native
resolution at 1440p. Maybe a tad bit
more oversharpened, but uh it's not a
big deal. I can see a little bit of
fuzziness sometimes around some leaves,
but now we're getting way higher FPS.
60s, 70s. This area over here is where
it drops the most usually in my
benchmark run. 60 frames per 58 still
dropping from 60. Okay, I did not expect
that, but yeah, it's a good
implementation of FSR4 and it it makes
quite a bit of a difference to the
smoothness of the game play. I'm just
going to select FSR native AA again to
see the difference. Yeah, there's about
like 8 to 10 FPS difference. Yeah,
dropping into the 40s sometimes
could be better. I guess we will need to
drop it down to like high settings
preset if we want 60 plus FPS all of the
time or enable some frame generation as
well. That's an option here. Let's use
FSRFG and see how it does. This is FSRFG
over native resolution. By the way, we
can actually start counting the FPS here
with the AMD frame generation. And uh
yeah, it puts us up into the ' 90s in
terms of input lag. It's pretty solid
actually. Even though our baseline FPS
were about 50 or 40 to 50 most of the
time in this area, this is not bad in
terms of input lag. I I think I could
live with this. And this is without AMD
anti-lag. So, I'm just going to turn it
on to make that input lag even better.
And now we're getting the smoothness of
80 frames per second.
It's working fine. Less input lag than
before, although I'm not seeing a huge
difference, honestly.
But it's still native resolution and
we're getting 90 frames per second. Is
it ideal to play with frame generation?
Not really. But since this is a single
player title, it actually works pretty
well. Yeah, that's not a problem, guys.
But I think I would actually choose to
play like this cuz now it gives you a
much better smoothness experience, you
know, on a high refresh rate monitor.
And it still gives you totally fine
input lags and the sharpness of native
resolution as well, cuz it's still
native resolution after all. Next is a
competitive shooter, Counter-Strike 2 at
1440p using high settings with four
times MSAA because I want to max out the
GPU all of the time. And let's start
counting those FPS. Seems like it's
going to be a really smooth experiment.
I missed that one. Come on. All right.
Got him this time. Yes. Oh, hello there,
kind sir. How's it going, buddy? There
we go. Head shot there. Good stuff. What
are you doing here again, dude? He just
spawned in front of me. I just killed
you, dude. There's There he is again.
Are you kidding me? Oh, boy. Okay, head
shot on that one. Come on. Okay. Well,
can we get the other one? Please show
yourself. There we go. We got him. Good
stuff. Oh boy. All right, another one
down. Should I reload? I guess so. Let's
do that. All right, we're good. There we
go. Another one down, guys. Yes, we're
doing this. And another one. Let's go.
I'm enjoying this a lot. Oh boy.
Obviously, guys, if you are playing this
game competitively, you will probably
play it on no scope. um on competitive
mode and low settings and then you're
going to see a way higher FPS, probably
a CPU bottleneck depending on your CPU.
But if you want to get the best visual
fidelity out of it, well, it's not the
best, but it's pretty damn close. It's
high settings after all, right? With
four times MSAA, it's going to be really
stable. Above 200 FPS on average, which
is nothing to sneeze at, my friends,
it's pretty How did I miss that one? No.
Come on, dude. Oh my god. He got the
revenge on us. Okay, I'm just going to
get him with the deagle now. There we
go. Good stuff. There's a guy over here.
Yep, there it is.
Okay, another one. Okay. Oh boy. Oh,
there's Seriously, stop coming from
there. Are you kidding me? We got No,
no, no, not from behind. Also, one thing
that I'm noticing here is that the VRM
allocation is quite high. Hey, the usage
itself is at 5 GB or 5 point something
like but the allocation is at
that was terrible. Uh at 10 GB that's
pretty crazy guys.
Hello kind sir and goodbye. Someone shot
at us with an AWP and now he's dead of
course. There we go. One bullet. No,
that's not enough. And he got us. We're
third place now. I fell off my friends.
Next is Doom: The Dark Ages at 1440p
resolution utilizing FSR native AA and
the Ultra Nightmare settings. Basically,
maximum settings here, but without path
tracing because that that's just an FPS
killer for AMD GPUs and also for Nvidia
GPUs. It's an FPS killer. Anyway, this
is so cute. By the way, I've never
noticed that these guys, those are
normalsized monsters and demons, but
they're so small. Anyway, we're getting
uh 60s, 50s. It's not amazing these FPS
for Doom. You know, I usually say that
like 100 FPS is where it's at for Doom.
Even though it's a single player title,
you want the FPS to be high because it's
a first person shooter and uh it's quite
a quick, fast-paced one as well. So,
although this is playable, it's not my
cup of tea. So, let's try to lower down
something to make it better. I'm going
to do FSR quality first. This is not FSR
4, by the way, unfortunately. In fact,
it's not even FSR 3.1, so you can't even
override it in the Radian settings.
At least it doesn't look as bad as the
FSR implementation in Cyberpunk 2077.
So, it's actually usable in my opinion
in this one. Although it makes things a
little bit soft and a little bit
shimmery as well on those edges, I think
it's still totally worth enabling here
in this game because it gives you those
sweet 100 fps or close to it uh on
average with the ultra nightmare
settings which look great even without
the rate race. Well, the path racing
because the game actually has rate
racing uh you know by default that's why
it's so intensive compared to other Doom
titles. dropping into the 70s as well.
This is a good baseline FPS to enable
some frame generation. At least with the
Nvidia's frame generation, I have seen
that this game doesn't have a ton of
input lag, so it's totally usable here.
But I'm not sure about the FSR frame
generation yet, but here we go. It is
enabled right now. All right. This is
why I haven't tested FSRFG because the
game crashes when MSI After Burner is
enabled. All right, here we go. Take a
look at the top right to see the FPS
now. It's yeah, super shimmery over here
with the quality FSR, but it's now
getting 140 plus FPS. I guess uh with
the frame generation, no major input lag
either. This feels really solid
actually. I'm also sad that this is not
FSR 3 uh.1, so we could enable FSR4 on
top of it with the override, but it is
what it is, my friends. This is why DLSS
is so much better cuz a lot of games are
actually implementing it. And if you
want the FSR4 uh upscaler without using
mods and whatnot and Optiscaler, well,
you got to wait basically until the
developers update FSR. Next up, we got
one of my favorite games of the entire
year so far, Kingdom Comet Deliverance
2. It's beautiful. It runs well. It's
well optimized. However, we're starting
here with 50ish FPS and the 5060Ti was a
bit faster at 60 FPS, drop dipping down
into the 50s, but not too much. Uh, at
least over in this area. So, because of
that, I will choose to play on the high
settings instead of ultra settings with
this one, which looks very similar, just
with a little bit more popping. But
right now, we're at 1440p ultra FSR 3.1
native AA. But this is one of those
cases where the FSR implementation is
being replaced with FSR4. So it looks
way better. First of all, I want to see
how quality FSR will look and perform
here. Maybe we don't even need to lower
it down to high settings. You know, if
it looks great in terms of performance,
it's amazing now. 80 fps. So, no
problems there. And in terms of visuals,
it is slightly softer, but it still
looks super similar to the native
resolution stuff. I think this looks
better with FSR quality now, FSR4 on
quality than if you were to disable FSR
altogether and play with the game's
built-in SMA T2X or 2TX or something
like that, because that's really soft in
this title. All right. And this is
actually great. It's not even dropping
into the 60s, you know. Well, now it is.
Now that we are in a forest area with a
lot of dense vegetation, it's dropping
slightly into the 60s, but it shouldn't
drop from 60 fps, I guess. Yeah, it's
pretty safe to say it's going to be a
great experience here with FSR 4 on
quality. But what about the high
settings? As I told you, I'll still test
that out. High at 1440p native
resolution with FSR4 native AA. Looking
fantastic here. Still, as you can see,
there's not a big difference comparing
this to ultra settings. And it's now
above 60 FPS here. Shouldn't drop too
much. Although, it might actually dip
down into the high50s inside of big
forest areas, dense vegetation, and so
on. But yeah, so far so good. Yeah, I
mean, I don't really see much of an
issue of playing this game on high
instead of ultra. It's just the shadow
popping on bushes and so on is much more
noticeable on high. But if you don't
really pay much attention to that stuff,
it's absolutely fine. You can play at
native resolution. Well, actually do
whatever you want. It's going to be a
great experience here in Kingdom Come
Deliverance 2. And be sure to buy the
game because it is a masterpiece. It's
really good one. Oh, look at that. We're
ending at 69 FPS average and 59 1% lows.
How amazing.
Next is an Unreal Engine 5 title, very
intensive one. Stalker 2 at 1440p using
the high settings preset and FSR native
AA. Note that we are actually using FSR
once again. It's working here with this
one. So that's awesome. And it makes the
game look super sharp and crispy. I
really like this guys. I mean, this game
is usually a total mess when it comes to
the visuals, honestly, without the FSR
native AA or FSR4's native AA or DLA
from Nvidia. Unfortunately, though, it's
still a little bit of a mess when it
comes to the performance, but you know,
it's Unreal Engine 5. Lumen is at work
here, so it wrecks the FPS and it gets
us around like 50 frames per second,
which is not half bad. Honestly, if FSR4
one quality can push it to 60 plus and
if it doesn't have a ton of artifacting
because last time that I tested it here
in this title, it had a ton of weird
looking vegetation and pixelation there
near this area actually. So, if they
manage to fix that, it is definitely the
way to go and it's going to be
fantastic. So, let's see if that works.
Here we go. quality FSR
and
I think Oh, okay. So, I'm still Yeah,
I'm still seeing that weirdness.
Sometimes if I move the camera really
fast, you can see Yeah, over there it's
really noticeable.
Ah, you know what? Aside from that, it
is so good looking. But then, yeah, it
has a lot of those issues still. FSR4
implementation in these UE5 titles isn't
the best, guys. And that's really a
shame because if it wasn't for that
pixelation issue, it would look
fantastic. It looks really close to what
the LSS can do. Aside from that, once
again, I really thought this was going
to be awesome. Anyways, with native AA
and FSR 3.1 frame generation enabled,
let's see if it gets better. In terms of
the input lag, it's instantly noticeable
since the baseline frame rate was 40 to
50 most of the time, you know. But I
mean, it's not too terrible given that
it's Stalker 2. It always has a big
amount of input lag, unfortunately.
Would I play like this? I think so.
Yeah, I would definitely choose the
quality FSR4
instead of this to play the game with if
it wasn't for the noise. But since it's
broken and noisy still, I would choose
this. Yeah, in terms of stability, it's
very good. In terms of the native AA,
it's also very good with FSR4. And frame
generation is working fantastic as well.
But it's a shame that we can't use FSR
quality. Wait a second. Let me try like
XSS ultra quality, which is actually the
same uh resolution scale as FSR quality.
This shouldn't have issues.
Uh, I mean around the gun things get
really soft and weird unfortunately,
but I guess
at least it doesn't have the issues with
the vegetation here. So, that's all
right. Now, I would still choose to play
with FSR native AA and frame generation
rather than this. This just it's super
soft, guys.
Oh, boy. Now it's Fortnite. We're
playing this one at 1440p using
DirectX12 epic settings, but I did
disable nanite, which also disables
lumen, which is rate tracing. You know,
hardware rate racing is also turned off,
of course. Let's go. And notice that I
didn't say stutter night, my friends.
That's because this doesn't really
stutter all that much compared to well,
previous versions of the game. You know,
it's in a good state now, so it actually
is pretty smooth. What is this dog
bones? What What do I need this for? I
don't want to. Okay, I can throw them.
Do they explo? What the hell is going
on? Hello, buddy. Oh my gosh, this is so
cute. But what is this? Why? Why would I
use this? What the Hello? Okay, what?
People are shooting at me. We got to go.
We got to go. Oh boy, that is so weird
and cute at the same time. Look at this.
It's so smooth. It's not stuttering.
doesn't have transitional stuttering or
whatever it's called. I I don't remember
the exact name right now for some
reason. But look at this. This is so
smooth. I'm not sure if it's because it
is once again an AMD GPU and it does
really well and and it's more smooth
than Nvidia GPUs in UE5, but this is
impressive for Fortnite, guys. I usually
call it stutter night, but it's not
stutter night here today. Hello.
Hello. Hey. Oh, I didn't know that this
was a pump shotgun thingy that you need
to reload. Anyway, we got him. Good
stuff. Good stuff. And we earned some uh
What is What is this? Okay, I can
destroy things with this. Oh boy, we're
going to see some explosions. Look at
that. 90s. It's pretty solid, guys. I
don't have complaints here in Fortnite,
honestly, with this GPU.
Yeah, this is really good. That's the
saw guy. Come on. I'm going to die.
Whoa. Whoa. What? What did I just do?
You can now side jump. That's so
interesting.
Oh, come on. Come on. Come on. Let me
let me get you. There we go. We got him.
Good stuff. Next up is the gorgeous Red
Dead Redemption 2. Guys, this game still
holds up super well after all of these
years. We're at 1440p resolution using
the benchmark king's optimized settings
for this game. These provide the best
visuals to performance ratio and they
make the game work really well. As you
can see, getting 100 frames per second
on the 960 XT at native 1440p with these
visuals is just marvelous, my friends.
Unfortunately though, we are stuck with
DAA. With the Nvidia GPUs, you now can
replace the DLSS with DAA uh via the
Nvidia app and do the override thingy.
On the AMD GPUs, you're gonna have to
use TAA at native resolution, which kind
of sucks, but at the same time, a lot of
people enjoyed the hell out of this game
with TAA anyways. And overall, it still
looks very good. It's just a bit soft.
But this is nothing short of an amazing
experience in Red Dead Redemption 2. It
takes advantage of a higher refresh rate
monitor as well since it's not closer to
60 frames per second. You can definitely
feel that smoothness from 100 frames per
second. Roach, please don't you crash on
me, buddy. We need to make that bastard
Bob sing. And here he is. Here he is.
Let's go. Come over here, Bob. Sing for
us. Sing.
There we go. This is the radio, my
friends, from the 1800s. You strapped
Bob to to the horse basically and he
screams, he sings. It's beautiful. This
is the Strawberry Town over here. It's
very intensive of an area. It usually
drops a couple of more FPS during
nighttime in Saint Deni, but this is
still as intensive as it gets. Aside
from that couple of FPS at night, but
let's go 90 something FPS. It still
keeps it above 90 frames per second at
all times. So, amazing experience. As I
said, this is just great in Red Dead
Redemption 2,
guys. GTA 5 enhanced is next and they
just updated it to have FSR4.
That's awesome because FSR3
implementation was pretty bad in this
one. Uh, now we're using the very high
rate tracing settings and I enabled the
high resolution rate reflections because
that comes disabled uh on the preset.
Everything else is set to the preset.
And I also disabled motion blur, but you
know that's motion blur. Nobody cares
about motion blur. Let's go. This is
getting us around 60 frames per second.
I'm curious to see it with the quality
FSR4. In terms of the visuals with
native AA, this is fantastic, guys. It's
really close to the LAA, if not pretty
much the same, if not slightly sharper
than the LA. It's fantastic. I love the
look of FSR4, guys. In most titles, it
works really well. So, let's go. Let's
speed through the city as usual. Getting
like 80 frames per second. Still pretty
good. 1% lows of 60. I think it will
drop from 60 fps, but still I want to
see it in Bob's uh bushes or Jack's
Hill. Yes. And I guess most of the time
it's going to be pretty stable. However,
it's not raining right now, and that
makes it a bit more intensive here in
these driving scenarios around the city.
Not in Bob's bushes. It will drop to the
same values while it's raining or not.
So, it doesn't really matter there.
Also, say goodbye to the ghosting that
was present in FSR 3.1 or 3 or whatever
it was previously because right now I'm
not go noticing any ghosting whatsoever.
So that's actually better than the LSS
and the LAA in terms of ghosting here
with FSR4. Pretty good implementation.
And in terms of the grass, everything is
super sharp. You can see all of the
individual leaves as well. Jack. Oh,
there he is. Okay. Hello, buddy. How's
it going? Anyway, let's go to Bob's
bushes. Okay. Here we go. And it drops
into the 50s. So mid50, low 50s actually
is the lowest there. 52 frames per
second. Not too terrible considering
it's rate racing and everything.
Goodbye, Bob. Um, you know, like on an
AMD card, it's still impressive that we
can do RT this well uh with this new
generation. It's all right, but I want
60 plus FPS all of the time. So, for
that, let's see that beauty of FSR4 on
quality. So instead of getting like 80s
or 70 to 80 FPS around here, we're
getting 100 plus. That's really solid.
And in terms of visuals,
it is once again really similar to the
LSS quality. I I feel like the
implementation of FSR in this game might
actually be better than the
implementation of the LSS. First of all,
again, we don't have ghosting uh on the
back of the car. Secondly, with the LSS4
on quality in this title, I notice some
more fuzzy things, you know, and some
more oversharpening. And over here,
I I'm still noticing a little tiny bit
of a difference compared to FSR4 Native
A, but it is really minor, guys. Even
here with all of the grass. This is very
impressive. I'm liking this a lot. Go.
Bye, Bob. Once again, what are you doing
here? I just killed you. Also, those
rate race reflections are amazing. Of
course, even with FSR4 on quality, this
is really I'm very impressed with this
implementation right here. Wow. Next is
Call of Duty War Zone. And this works
really well on AMD GPUs to the point
where this surpasses the 5060 Ti. In
performance, we're at 1440p native
resolution with fidelity FX CAS to
sharpen up the image and the ultra
settings preset without depth of field
and high textures. Here we go, guys. Oh
boy. Okay, we're dropping in a downtown
area and down here we're getting 120s,
130s, 110s at times. I'm going to start
counting the FPS. It's really smooth.
Doesn't stutter whatsoever. My gosh, I I
mispressed the key. Okay, there we go.
It's F to enter the vehicle. Okay. All
right. But yeah, guys, as you can see,
this is going to be a flawless
experience in Call of Duty War Zone or
any other Call of Duty for that matter.
They all run really well on AMD GPUs,
and this has the power needed to uh make
it perfect in in Call of Duty. Oh, yes.
Oh, yes. All right, let's go. Grab some
uh packs over here of armor. Yeah, there
he is, bastard. Come over here. Come
over here. All right, got him. I'm
downed him. I downed him. Okay, first
kill is in the bag. Good stuff. Okay.
And I guess we can actually take a look
at the entire city from up here, right?
Let's check it out. There we go. 120s.
Doesn't really affect FPS by a whole
lot, actually. So, what the
What? What are you? See, that's one of
the reasons why I don't really love this
game too much.
Um, it just doesn't feel like a serious
game anymore. I I like the weapons. I
like the map. I I like the vibes, you
know, but then you come across those
guys with skins and Nicki Minaj running
around killing people and it's just
weird, dude. It's a high refreshment
experience, guys. It looks really nice
as well. The game has FSR4, by the way,
which I went to check it out actually.
Obviously, you don't need to play with
upscaling here, but if you want to make
it like 144 plus FPS all of the time,
there's the option to enable it. Okay.
And wow, that looks great, actually.
Okay. Just making sure here status is
active on FSR4.
And uh it's it's going to be a little
bit better. Although, just like the LSS
in this game, the performance that you
gain from enabling the upscaler isn't
really that huge. Oh boy, I'm stunned.
Okay, wait a second. I'm fine, though.
Fine. Come on. Got one. Got one. Okay.
All right. All good. There. Another one
there. Yes, there is. Yep. Oh, no.
I should have taken my time and
reshielded uh rearmored up. Yeah. All
right. Well, pretty good performance,
really good upscaling here. Now, it's
been great so far, but we got to go back
to UEI5. Unfortunately, we're at 1440p
in this one. Using high settings,
software rate tracing on low uh and FSR
native AA. This is FSR 4 as well. And
it's The Elder Scrolls Oblivion uh
Remastered. Okay, Elder Scrolls 4
Oblivion Remastered. And yeah, it's the
performance isn't great. Unfortunately,
it's expected at this point from UE5
titles, right? A little bit of
stuttering is expected. However, it is a
bit more stable than the 560 Ti, its
competitor. Once again, for some reason,
the frame times are quite a bit smoother
on AMD cards, which is pretty
impressive. Yeah, it it's nice and
stableish, aside from the Unreal Engine
5 related stutters, which won't go
anywhere, unfortunately, after a shader
compilation. Now, let's check it out
with quality FSR4, though. I think this
is going to be a bit bad because we got
tons of grass here. At least it was bad
previously when I tested it with the
970.
Maybe they have fixed it because I'm not
seeing the issues that we saw in Stalker
2, for example, with FSR4 on quality
enabled. And this is definitely the way
to go, by the way, in my opinion, if
those issues aren't present, because it
looks really good still. But I will go
back to where I saw major pixelation
issues with the 970 previously. It was
right here.
Yeah, they fixed it, guys. They fixed
it. They Yes, they've done it. Oh, no.
These ones are still weird. No.
Oh, that's such a shame because over
here for example, there was tons of
pixelation. Okay, now I'm seeing it
again.
Damn it. It's sad. And with native AA,
it works really well. So, I'm not sure
why it doesn't with quality. Oh boy.
Anyway, it does get 60 plus FPS all of
the time. So, if you wanted to use FSR 3
instead of FSR 4, it would get these
FPS. The FPS are basically the same
between the two. Um, and it would be
playable with above 60 FPS almost all of
the time. And now it's Assassin's Creed
Shadows, guys. This game is super
demanding. It shows right now 50ish
frames per second, but we're playing at
1440p utilizing AMD's FSR4 on quality
and the high settings preset with rate
race for global illumination diffused
everywhere. So, this is pretty
demanding. Of course, if you lower it
down to low, you could get 60 plus FPS,
I guess. But yeah, that starts looking
pretty bad. So, I would keep the
settings on high. As you can see, it
still hits like 60 FPS sometimes,
especially outside of town areas, like
right here, 60s. Lots of vegetation, and
it doesn't have a problem with FSR4 on
quality. This looks 1440p to me. It's
really high quality, the upscaler, and
this is a good baseline FPS, even though
it drops into the 40s sometimes uh to
play with frame generation in this title
because frame generation in this game
can be used even with a 40fps baseline.
They optimized the game with that in
mind and it's a really good
implementation of FG. So, I'm going to
enable that over quality FSR here and
same settings of course. And now we can
get up to 100 FPS. Look at that. While
looking pretty much the same. No
artifacting, no ghosting. It's one of
the best FG implementations once again.
And we get up to 100 FPS. It is so much
smoother. It's also still really
responsive. I can't notice a big
difference. And that's really
impressive, guys. Uh because again in
most games you enable frame generation
with 50 fps or 40 fps and it's terrible.
It's a really bad experience in terms of
input lag. But yeah, it's really good to
the point where I feel like these are
the best settings to be had with the
1960 XT. It does provide you that higher
refresh rate experience. Feels amazing.
Yeah, it just works really well right
now. I'm very impressed with this
implementation of FSR actually. Now it's
Battlefield 2042. We're playing this one
at 1440p resolution using the high
settings without rate tracing or dynamic
resolution scale. All righty. Here we
go. Good FPS, guys. Very good FPS,
actually. There's one over there with a
shield, I think. Oh, shieldy boy. Okay,
we got him. All right, no problems.
Yeah, it's going to be a high refresh
rate experience at native 1440p
resolution. See, in well optimized
titles, this thing is really good. Seems
like the enemy team is actually quite
decent at this game. So, we need to be
very careful. Uh, some enemies over in
that direction, I guess. Let's go over
here. Are they camping in that building
again? Wait, there's a guy here. Oh, no.
Come on. He's dead. Nice. Good, good,
good, good, good. Hello there. That's a
friendly. Okay, thankfully TK is not a
thing here in this one. All right, at
least not in this mode. Come on. Come
on. Where is he? There we go. Got him.
That friendly. Okay. Why are we all over
the place and them as well? There's
someone inside of there. Oh my gosh. I'm
going to kill myself with my own
grenade.
[Music]
Okay, they're capturing the objective.
This is bad. This is very bad. Uh where
are they? One there. Got him. But yeah,
guys, even though this isn't the best
Battlefield game, you know, it's
actually a lot of fun to play these
days. I I am enjoying it. Every time I
hop into it, it's fun and it performs
really well, of course. Uh oh, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. How
am I alive? I should not be alive at
this point. Okay, there he is. Goodbye,
sir. No, he still got us. It was that
one. I didn't even see the guy. Oh boy.
Anyway, guys, you get the idea, right?
Really good performance here in BF 2042.
I hope the next Battlefield title runs
well as well. Next up is Alan Wake 2,
guys. A gorgeous game, but super
demanding one. As you can see, 40ish
frames per second. We are at 1440p
native resolution using the high
settings preset with no rate tracing.
It's a very bad idea to utilize rate
tracing in this one. Even this 5060 Ti,
which is a bit better using rate racing,
struggles in this one. So, just keep
that setting off. All right, I'm still
going to try it a little bit later, but
it's a terrible idea. Anyway, 40ish
frames per second is very playable for a
game like this. It's single player,
slower paced. We're seeing a couple of
frame time spikes here and there.
They're not really too obnoxious or
noticeable, but I mean, I love my 60fps
even though this works fine like this. I
think I would utilize some FSR to make
it more playable or more enjoyable, more
smooth, you know. So, that's exactly
what I'm going to do here. Let's stop it
there and do FSR quality. Now,
unfortunately, this doesn't support FSR
3 or 3.1 or FSR4. So, we're stuck with
FSR2, but in this title, for some
reason, FSR2 is really good looking. I
can notice instantly that it's a little
bit softer, but I don't mind it, guys.
It works phenomenally as an upscaler in
this game, even while moving like this.
There's a bit of noise, yes, around the
character, especially when moving very
fast, but it's not super noticeable and
it puts our FPS up into the 70s as you
can see. So much smoother experience
like this, uh, with the tradeoff of it
being slightly blurriier. Those finer
branches and vegetation and so on, like
finer details on the vegetation are
going to be a little more noisy, but
that's not the end of the world. What's
the end of the world is those little
frame time spikes. I'm not liking those
and I don't usually see them in Allen
Wake 2. So, I'm not sure why those are
happening. Maybe driver issues because
Nvidia GPUs, the 50 series back when
they came out, they actually had this
stuttering issue and it was a driver
related problem. Now, let's enable that
rate tracing. I'm going to set it to low
rate tracing. Okay. And this is still
with FSR quality. And as you can see,
yeah, it goes back into the 40s at 960p
resolution internally upscale to 1440s.
So, not good, right? Unless you want a
30 fps experience out of this, I would
stay away from rate racing. So, rate
racing is better left off in this one.
And then we're back up into the 70s. Now
it's Indiana Jones and the great VRM
eater at 1440p resolution utilizing the
supreme settings preset with texture
pool size set to maximum as well cuz we
can with 16 GB unless you start using
path tracing of course and upscaling is
set to native TAA because unfortunately
this game doesn't support FSR4 and it
also doesn't have FSR native AA over
here so we're stuck with Pashki TAA
anyway. way. Over here we can get like
50 to 60 frames per second because I
fixed the popin issues. Shadow popin as
well as object popin is no more. But
that means lowering down our FPS into
the 50s from 60 plus most of the time.
For that, by the way, you just need to
type this command right here. Our LOD
scale 5. If I set it to the default one,
you can see that our FPS jump up to 67,
68, almost 69. Nice.
But there's a ton of pop in there. Super
noticeable in those bushes. So, I really
recommend this guys. And this way, it's
still a playable experience. Not amazing
really. I thought it was going to
perform a little bit better actually cuz
this game is quite easy to run if you
don't use path tracing. Um, but yeah, it
drops into the 50s. But let's check it
out with FSR on quality since that will
improve our FPS by quite a lot. Uh,
again, it's not FSR4, but it's not
looking too bad whatsoever. I'm going to
start counting our FPS. Frame time is a
little bit weird. It has those little
micro stitters there, which I I don't
know why that's happening, but it's
really smooth. Anyways, I don't notice
it whatsoever. I actually need to check
that FSR4 is disabled. It is indeed not
active because it doesn't have the check
mark there. Um, but this is a really
good implementation of whatever version
this FSR is. FSR2, FSR3, I don't know,
but it looks really good. Now, this is
the most intensive part in my benchmark
run getting over here. And it only drops
to like 62 frames per second. 63 62
again right there. Yeah, this is solid.
I would play like this. And it looks
good at the same time. No popping
issues. Great. It's good. Again, it's
not path tracing. with bat tracing it
can look a bit better but it's not night
and day actually that setting is way
beyond diminishing returns even for
Nvidia high-end GPUs you know 69 FPS on
the average is there at the end guys
that's amazing and now we have yet
another gorgeous title Horizon Forbidden
West at 1440p using FSR3 native AA and
the very high settings preset and guys
this actually has FSR4 that's beautiful
I I love to see this active over there.
Uh and it makes all of the difference.
Like this is FSR native A8 looks as good
as the LAA guys in this game. Wow.
Unfortunately, it does drop into the
50s. So, this is still not what I would
utilize with this GPU. I think with FSR4
on quality, it will be perfect if it's
anything like DLSS. And indeed, once
again, like yeah, this this is really
good, guys.
Oh yes. I mean, it is not as good as
DLSS4. It's about the LSS3 in terms of
visuals, but it's so much better than
what AMD had before. And the LSS3
already looked really, really pretty.
Even the LSS2, in my opinion, looked
pretty at 1440p resolution. So, here we
go. We're getting 80ish frames per
second. No stuttering whatsoever. I've
seen stuttering issues on 12 GB GPUs in
the past in this particular title
playing on very high settings and very
high textures uh in this area as well.
Yet this one since we do have 16 GB of
it, it's awesome. It doesn't slow down
one bit. Doesn't have a single stutter.
Anyway, yeah, 100 fps sometimes 80s
there. And this is the Burning Shores
DLC as well. It looks just as good as
native resolution here with the native
AA. It's pretty impressive. And my
friends, we have arrived at yet another
conclusion time. I'll still have more
games running right here while we talk a
little bit about the RX960
XT 16 GB GPU. And please, if you're
buying one of these cards, do not buy
the 8 GB version. That's very bad in
2025. Same goes for the 5060Ti. Anyway,
as we've seen, this is a pretty solid
1440p GPU with the help of FSR4 whenever
that's available. It gets really close
in visual fidelity compared to the LSS,
and that's amazing. I really love to see
it. More games are being supported these
days, but it's not without its issues,
of course. And compared to the 5060 Ti,
if they're similar in price, you should
definitely go with the Nvidia GPU.
However, this is $350 and the other one
is $430. And for an $80 difference, I
think this is definitely better. First
of all, it's better price to
performance, of course, no doubt about
it. And even with the advantages of
DLSS, a little bit lower power
consumption, and the 10% overall faster
performance on the 5060 Ti 16 GB, I
think this is worth it at 350 bucks. But
it all comes down to pricing of course.
And I would say that if this is only
like 50 bucks less expensive than the
5060 Ti 16 gig, I would go with the
Nvidia GPU because of again 10% higher
performance which can make a little bit
of a difference in some titles like
Kingdom Come Deliverance 2 comes to
mind. But the major thing that does it
for me is that DLSS. It's really nice to
have. It's widely implemented in a ton
of games and it's usually a really good
implementation as well. It it just
works, you know, and with this one,
yeah, you can make it work in more games
than it does right now with just
standard settings, default settings, but
you got to put in some work as well. And
if you're willing to do that, this
becomes even better value then because,
well, you get FSR4 in a lot more games.
But yeah, that's my opinion. FSR4 is
very good, but the LSS is still just a
little bit better. And I value upscalers
a lot with this kind of performance at
1440p because they're very usable, of
course. But aside from that, guys, this
is still the better price performance
GPU, and it is a good buy. You won't
really be disappointed, I think. And
especially if you play at 1080p
resolution and you don't rely on the
upscaling part of FSR4, just the native
AA, it's going to be even better, of
course. I mean, displays everything at
1440p fine. At 1080p, it's going to be
flawless. So, that's been it for this
one. Thanks very much for watching this
video. I hope you guys enjoyed. Thanks
to AMD for sending this card for review.
And I'll catch you in the next one very
soon. As always, love you all. Bye-bye.